Khloe Kardashian claps back at a troll
online who asked if she misses her old
face I really think I'm in a good place
but I think working on your personal
growth something that will be a forever
um Mission but always remember to be
kind it all went down when the reality
star shared this clip of her workout
doing a series of exercises with her
daughter true nearby I never regret
getting a workout in if I try to
procrastinate whatever I just always
feel so good and accomplished so then I
feel like the rest of my day is great
that's when a hater slid into the
comments to ask do you miss your old
face implying Coco's undergone a whole
lot of plastic surgery I don't take it
too seriously because God only knows if
I looked at their photos what they look
like and in real life close response a
simple no I also don't care like it is
what it is shortly after the online
exchange the good American and founder
shared two quotes to her insta story
which may or may not have been a
response to that harsh critic one
encouraging people to speak with love
the other reflecting on the importance
of change and finding yourself maybe the
journey isn't so much about becoming
anything maybe it's about Unbecoming
everything that isn't really you so you
can become who you are meant to be in
the first place for me I think it's
important to show people you can turn
your life around you can go through hell
and high water but you can still come
out and have a beautiful positive happy
life of course this all comes after
Chloe shutdown claims about her weight
loss in January when a follower accused
her of achieving her slim down physique
by using an anti-diabetic injectable
meant for chronic weight management it
sold under a few names most notably
ozempic which is rumored to be abused by
Hollywood stars to shed lbs fast
but Coco slammed the claim saying let's
not discredit my years of working out I
get up five days a week at six am to
train working out is one of my new
obsession healthy obsessions Flo added
please stop with your assumptions I
guess New Year still means mean people
that's bizarre to me and you would think
people would be happy that I'm staying
healthy and fit and when it comes to
plastic surgery Coco keeps it real what
is in the media is sort of things that
we feel we need to film because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see them last year she
admitted she's thinking about going
under the knife to boost her bra size
I'm really contemplating getting my
boobs done I'm wearing a latex top with
like a bra top so they look great right
now and I wish they look like this all
the time she also addressed all the
speculation that she'd gotten a nose job
not only did she confirm it she doubled
down tweeting that her only regret was
that she didn't do it sooner my whole
life I would say I've always wanted my
nose done like forever but it's in the
middle of your face and it's scary to
think about but I finally got the
courage and I did it and I love it
[Music]
thank you